hello to mr straw thanks for joining us
i did put it to mr cleveland about uh
what we have said and what china might
have said to us tell us how those back
channels work especially in a situation
like this when we are trying to get them
to stay out of a war that could make the
difference between tens of thousands of
people dying and not
in any acute situation it's essential to
have what you describe as a back channel
and indeed called back channels so
there's a confidential
conversations between
diplomats who are trusted only on each
side also have to trust each other
and typically i mean
they take place
completely away from scrutiny i'll just
give you one example
when
president obama wanted to reestablish
some relationship with iran which led to
the nuclear deal in 2015 there were two
years of back channel negotiations
between american and iranian officials
which were quite deniable
uh but which
uh ensured that when they got to formal
negotiations they actually had more or
less got it precooked as the saying goes
in the diplomatic trade
okay um
what do you make of of what you're
hearing then and
the fact that china is saying no we're
not involved at all and how dare you
suggest this and the united states is
saying we can see what's going on what
what role would you play if you were
still uh the uk's foreign secretary what
would be happening behind the scenes
well
what i can see is is that uh china has
been
looking at the situation
uh it hasn't it has nothing to
particularly to thank the united states
for it it's benefited hugely from
the relaxation of uh
trade
restrictions which took place
30 years ago but the united states and
the west benefits as much as china does
from china's trade and china is a great
nation and one of the things about both
china and these days russia is this
sense that these are nations which were
humiliated
uh by the west in china's case were
humiliated in russia's case
are being humiliated
as a result of the collapse of the of of
the berlin wall and all that's happened
30 years it's on so they don't really
feel their
the west end of thing on the other hand
uh the chinese level not stupid
far from it
and their prosperity does indeed depend
on trade with the the west and only a
tiny amount on trade with russia whose
economy is so much smaller uh than it is
is china's and of course its population
is so much smaller to so
the chinese be trying to work it out
just and and what they think they've now
decided or should have understood is
that this is a war that uh president
putin is not lost but he's certainly not
winning uh and even if he does quotes
win it will be
a a victory which will be hollow so
that's what's going on there
the only in my view i mean i think this
is widely shared
the only man who could really
push putin into a corner getting off uh
this um
brutal outrageous adventure of of his
is um the prime the chinese president
and that's of course important you know
for the west for people
uh
like our prime minister and the united
states president to push
with the chinese as well
yeah mr shaw we're very lucky to have
you on today because of course uh
foreign affairs very much
dominating the news headlines we're
hearing that the prime minister our
prime minister is heading to saudi
arabia later on
um today to talk about trying to source
a different
customer a different client when it
comes to oil given the sanctions that
we've got in place against russia but we
know that the saudis
killed 81 people in one day
on saturday uh certainly this weekend
how can we do business with a country
that we bring up um their their
behavior towards fellow human beings and
they continue to do it ever since your
government was in power because of
course you also did business with them
we did
um and it and it's true um
across the world that you're faced with
these
moral hazards
so the answer is uh
how do you do business in practice well
with a peg on your nose
um but it's
that here's here's the problem and that
and then there will be people saying
well just refuse to take saudi oil i
mean let me just
point out too by the way
that texas
um
the lone star state of the united states
it too executes a
quite significant number of people and
with a very very rickety criminal
justice system certainly compared to
ours so just point that out
um and and there is a relativitism here
so
when iran which is uh
kills more people judicially than any
other country executes people if they
ever announce this there's huge
condemnation around the world
if it's saudi arabia it's muted and if
it's texas on the whole people say
nothing about it
anyway how do you do it um we need saudi
oil i also just say as the world's
waking up we also need iranian oil
um and we need venezuelan oil and so
you will have to see not these not these
things put aside altogether
but frankly twin track negotiations um
but
in the case of saudi arabia iran and
venezuela for example those countries
need
hard currency they want to sell more oil
at the highest price they can i know but
they won't mind at all about
um
putting russia's nose out of joint if
they can
take a greater market share
of things than uh of their own oil and
gas markets that then does russia so
that's what happens okay just looking at
the figures actually apparently texas
executed six people last year i take
your point but it's significantly fewer
than what uh saudi arabia got up to just
over this weekend let me ask you finally
if i may about fracking um your previous
constituency of course of course up
there in lancashire very much in the
heart of a fracking uh territory
quadrila has to decide whether to start
capping those wells or not given the
situation that we found ourselves in
should we
cap those wells nonetheless or should we
wait
it depends on the
geology um i mean i've never been
opposed in principle to fracking
and i've seen it operate elsewhere and
and and
it's it's not about there's a huge
amount of of
talk about of what it does
in in all the countries where fracking
is taking place it's been perfectly okay
the difficulty um
is the geology of that part of
lancashire uh and
it did lead to a number of okay very
minor earthquakes um but you talk about
an earthquake
you think of buildings tumbling down
that happens that there are many more
natural earthquakes of that size
than there have been caused by fracking
but nonetheless
uh you've got to understand it from the
public's point of view um that
there is real anxiety uh in the in that
part of lancashire uh about the
geological effects and effects on their
own houses
of uh fracking so that's the issue for
me it's a it's a if you like a practical
one uh rather than uh am i opposed in
principle to fracking why should i be
opposed in principle to fracking is
another way of getting oil and gas out
of the ground and i'm very much in favor
of all the climate change change
policies which my party is pursuing but
meanwhile
we need a lot of gas and oil we do uh
former foreign secretary we are out of
time it's always great to have you on
the show do come back more often thank
you very much indeed thank you
thanks a lot